nick curios he's been trying to convince
us that he's a better man yeah he says
he's over he's over all that he's come
through it and he can he can take him he
can take defeat there's no problem
it's all okay and then he threw one of
the most almighty tantrums ever say look
at this
[Applause]
it's the second one that is so
pathetically childish like get over some
of your big baby he's just trying to
show that he cares
it's good branding he's the bad boy
we're talking about it's not really not
okay it's not okay
like this and if serena williams had had
been violent like that that would be
something well actually serena williams
has done stuff like that she hasn't and
she has been roundly casting something
rude to a lion judge yeah she did you
know that's really really aggressive
it's really nice jeremy have you ever
smashed things in your job i've still
got a tennis racket i bought about 20
years ago
i could never smash it they cost them
bob because you all strike me i've known
you a long time you've always struck me
as extraordinarily calm person when all
around is exploding i don't smash things
i mean i'm often surrounded by people
who are smashing gates often with guns
and quite big ones but no i uh
i don't see i mean i guess maybe that's
his way of dealing with his rage and
disappointment
but to be honest i think that if you
explode like that it shows you've failed
it does but it also shows this
extraordinary burning bash that he has
inside of which like macular i don't
think mcenroe could help himself this is
what some people just don't buy that
it's terrible it's like it's like people
who beat their spouses like it's because
just all this passion that i had for you
no you get a grip
is only beating a tennis racket
i know but you know you shouldn't
display your anger by by being doing
violent acts we're we've evolved past
this i think but it's entertaining and
we're talking about it i think honestly
well i think it's brian dignified
i think he's doing it i think he does it
deliberately yeah yeah i think it's
branding i think you know 20 years
should we smash up this table for
brandon well i don't want that to be my
brand but the bad girl of the piers
morgan is it's when he picks up the
second racquet
is that one i mean that is it's pathetic
if you're watching mr curies i think you
do watch the show just grow up your big
baby